21 lawsuits now filed against desean
watson two more today here's the key
though this statement appeared
in my email box this afternoon and i was
stunned when i opened it up
and i saw not just the 18 massage
therapists
have supported deshawn watson but that
each one
attached a name and with each name
there was a quote regarding her
experiences with deshaun watson
some of the massage therapists i thought
went
a little a little too far from my liking
into editorializing about
the veracity of the other complaints
just because one
massage therapist wasn't assaulted by
desean watson doesn't mean that none
ever were shireen but you know the other
reality
and and there were two big takeaways one
if you can round up
18 massage therapists and get statements
with their names attached to them how
can you act like you have no idea who
the 21 people who sued you are which
rusty harden has said multiple times
and then secondly when you throw in mary
the
individual who spoke to jenny verentis
of si.com different name but but
mary is how she's known in the story one
plus 21 plus 18
is 40. i and and i've seen that reaction
including from former nfl line and
jermon bushrod said i played 12 years
i didn't i never had half that many
therapists during my entire career
40 massage therapists in a fairly
limited time frame
is causing a lot of people to say this
is just off
so yeah look i know what rusty harden's
trying to do but i feel like
every time he makes a statement there's
something in there
that in a roundabout way undermines his
his bigger picture
objective
it's troubling to me mike the 40. i
that's my
big takeaway from this is how why how
often are you getting massage to have 40
because
a lot of them said in those statements
multiple times right
so how often is he getting massages why
are they all women i mean
most nfl players as i said before get
massages and they get them frequently i
get it i i understand the need for it
hey
i've had massages too before covet love
it it's a great experience
i went to the same one almost all the
time most guys have
one massage therapist maybe two that
they use but they employ these people
like
emmett smith when i know went and got
multiple massages from the same person
all the time he had a person on call
who who showed up and and did his
massages
and most of the time frankly mike
they're male
masseuses who do these things for nfl
players
and these were all women now maybe he
also went to some men which adds to the
total of massage therapists that he's
used over the years so that's
my trouble with this and then you're
right the
the first woman that rusty harden has
quoted in the story
talks about oh i giggled when i saw that
that
desean requested a towel had a towel i
taught him to do that to use the towel
instead of the
all right you just said that you proved
part of her statement that he used a
towel right so
and then she went on to say as you have
pointed out
to say that i can't believe that desean
would do this that i just don't think
they're being truthful well
just because you and i go into a
restaurant and have different
experiences doesn't mean
our experiences weren't true you might
have had great service and a great meal
and i might have had crappy service and
a crappy meal
that doesn't mean either one of us was
lying we just had different
different experiences in this same
restaurant mike so
there are so many questions with this
thing i don't know how this is going to
end
but there are a lot of questions i have
starting with
why so many massage therapists and why
use instagram for massage therapist
and it's entirely possible all 40 of the
massage therapists who are now
involved in this case the 18 whose names
we know the 22 whose names we don't
absolutely entirely possible they're all
telling the truth that that
that is one possible way to explain this
and i i believe shireen because
last week if you remember rusty hardin's
statement said that they have received
unsolicited statements of support for
deshaun watson
from multiple massage therapists and my
reaction that was well
how can you say you need to tell us the
names of the people who are suing and
you're not going to supply the names of
the people who support him
and lo and behold that's what they did
today
i think that when it's time for deshaun
watson to start responding to these
complaints
the first line of defense very well may
be some effort to
either dismiss the cases as pleaded or
seek a more definite statement all in an
effort to shine a light
on the fact that you've got 19
plaintiffs
none of whom will attach a name to it
none of whom can be objectively
identified or verified by anyone other
than watson to the extent he kept any
records that could be reconstructed but
i think back to the antonio brown case
still pending sexual assault and rape
he's he's accused of rape britney
taylor's name has been attached to the
lawsuit from day one
ben roethlisberger was accused of rape
in a civil complaint that was filed in
november of 2009
the first step toward what eventually
was his four-game suspension in 2010
the individual attached her name to that
civil
claim for rape i'm not saying you have
to do it
it just gets to a point where when you
have 19
and they're all represented by the same
guy and they're
all proceeding anonymously like is is it
possible that
one of the 19 is fine with her name
being disclosed
but she's been pressured by tony buzz
because they want to have this grand
united front
of 19 jane doe plaintiffs just to make
it
harder for deshaun watson and rusty
harden know what the hell is going on i
just
that that's my concern especially when i
see statements like the one i saw last
night
from tony busby the explanation out of
the blue
on social media as to why he had not
made good on his promise to submit
evidence to the houston police
department for a potential criminal
prosecution
and and this idea that he didn't do it
because he ran for mayor
and he was critical of the former police
chief
when he ran for mayor even though art
acevedo is no longer the police chief in
houston rusty hardin's got a son
or some other relative that works for
the houston police i
look i i conspiracy mike
can be in full effect any given moment i
can be as cynical as anyone
and there are reasons to be cynical
about the things people say but the idea
that the houston police department would
not take seriously
the complaints made by 19
individuals now 21 individuals because
somebody's got a problem with the lawyer
who represents them
i i i think that's ridiculous look i got
concerns about tony busby
and his tactics but i i still am going
to give
his 21 clients the full benefit of the
doubt and see what their stories are
it's possible all 21 are telling the
truth and tony busby is just doing
things i don't like
so i i i was i that was just one of
those when i saw that last night i
thought what in the hell
is this and if i was a family member of
one of these 19 individuals who was
suing i'd say
fire tony busby and go hire somebody
else because this guy's getting in the
way of your
opportunity to get full and complete
justice
yeah at this point mike and as you
pointed out over the last couple weeks
if
if you're married in that story and
decide to sue
you should go see somebody else other
than tony busby i think it would serve
you well to
to go get a different outlier but yeah
it makes no sense that you wouldn't take
this to the houston police department
um they're going to investigate right
that's what they do
and whether they have rusty harden has a
son or relative or whatever within the
police department i still believe that
the houston police department
would investigate if you have evidence
here they're going to look into this
they're going
to talk to these women uh that that have
accused
deshaun watson of what they've accused
him of so
yeah i didn't understand that at all i
still don't get it
and i would look forward to hearing from
the houston police department and where
they
stand on this and and why do you want to
agitate
gratuitously if you're tony busby and
you're trying to get justice and
i i don't know how rusty harden and
desean watson are looking at this
but quarter public opinion tony busby
had a huge lead based upon the first
week or so
over the course of the past couple of
days rusty hard and desean watson
thanks to busby's bizarre comment from
last night
and the 18 individuals who are on the
record
they've made up some ground but at the
at the core and i see this reaction more
than anything else on social media
why do you have 40 different people in a
year or so time frame
who are giving you these massages and uh
if and when desean watson is ever under
oath in one of these cases
that's one of the questions he will be
at
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports